[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
hi hello welcome to GameSpot's
livestream of the indie mix we have a
bunch of great independent games because
it's GDC weekend Game Developers
Conference is happening in our backyard
and thankfully we have access to a lot
of developers who want to show off their
games
now the any mix is sort of this event
that is held for developers who are
currently working on independent games
of course and then we also got in
contact with people running the indie
mix so we can have them come in and
actually play their games for us live
here on GameSpot so yeah first off we're
gonna kick off with one that we had last
year called moita and I'm joined by
Petri who is a word on the game how you
doing man I'm good yeah yeah I'm doing
it myself we're just starting with GDC
weekend
there's a lot going on so yeah this is a
hell of a way to kick off the week
though because I'm very excited about a
lot of things that are being shown off
on the indie mix including noise uh so
we're gonna cut to that and we're gonna
have Petri play his own game and we'll
see how good he does and his own game on
overtime but just before we went live I
was talking about how like you can't
judge him for how he plays because he
made this or he is making this yeah so
um I mean while you're kind of playing a
game here kind of run us through what
Noida is so no it's a it's a rope light
so it's procedurally generated game and
and the thing is that every pixel in
this game instead of simulated they have
like physical properties so like you see
water is sort of like ghost goes down
and drains so all of these assets kind
of react yeah like sit in the simulated
way so like there's some liquids here
I'm just gonna throw this bomb here it's
gonna explode and bad we're gonna see
you know liquid draining down went up
this is kind of nasty liquid so I don't
really want to touch it this is like the
one thing you can kind of see is above
my head here there's like this water
drop and that tells me what I'm covered
in so right now I'm a bit wet so what
that means as fire is not gonna ignite
as me okay so your your interactions
with the environment also effects like
your own properties and like buffs and
debuffs
yeah okay so like here's an oil lamp
electrified
it's gonna drop down and oils gonna
spill and it's go set this wood here
okay
so now like because I'm wet I can kind
of go through these flames but I don't
really want to do that that much because
I'm really getting on fire and here's
all this nasty green liquid that I do
not want to touch because I'm gonna get
poisoned if I touch it and here's some
more poison and here's someone who was
oh no now I'm poisoned okay maybe we can
just it'd be good here's some oil so now
jump into the oil that's gonna cover me
so now I'm covered in oil which is much
better than poison says that the negate
your poison effects yeah cool yeah but
now I'm slippery so you can see I'm
sliding down okay oh wow this is yeah
there's a little there's a lot going on
in terms of yeah at least in the early
game we could see a lot of the different
things that are a lot of different
properties are going on into this world
so I got I got a ass like as someone
who's like designing this how do you
keep balance of the different types of
things that are actually going on so
like you don't generate a level that's
too difficult for someone but it is
there a way to make sure that there's
always a way out or yeah we've done it
so that there should be always a path
okay so here was a bunch of oil here
that got set on fire huh also because
I'm covered in oil out me to try to
avoid this fire oh yeah so yeah we we've
made it so that dirt oh my god thirst
okay let's see
and you know their their bodies are also
simulated so like it's like having their
yeah everything's like live physics it
yeah
within very much within the pixel art
yeah yeah okay
yeah that's that's it genuinely
impressive what see you so from last
year you showed this game off with us
look at what has changed since since
then so there's been a bunch of bigger
changes that you've been down but
they're kind of like very well hidden in
places sometime oh if I should be
telling you about them all right but
sort of the visible things that have
changed we have now new sound effects
finally proper and but the music of from
grottoes we have this dynamic soundtrack
that's happening oh cool so I've done a
bit of updating so this is one of the
things that has changed so the way the
structure of the game works is there's
sort of these levels and and once you
make it down enough you get to this
place and here what you get is I get
here here's my health so here I get my
health back up and this is one of the
things that's new so I had when I
started this game I had like three balls
I have one more and no more fun so this
thing will give me my farms essentially
back so so okay
refresh my my stuff and then I get to
use the shop and Gannett oh no we were
lacking lacking six dollars oh you spent
too much money man got a and this is one
of the things that's new as well we have
now sort of perks so once you make it
here you get these abilities and get to
pick one of these three so one of the
things you get to do here which is a big
part of this game is you get to modify
your wands and make your own spells okay
and you attach those to your weapons to
give them different things yeah so like
like now this this blue wand your treats
these purple things right so I can put
this purple thing into my my qualm wand
and
I will shoot little prick more of our
fire oh sweet
but the drawback of this is it's not got
as much mana so like I see this is kind
of like ran out of mana it's gonna be
like this okay all right so I you
playing with a lot of different
variables here in terms of like not just
like in the level generation but also
yeah the equipment you got yeah there's
a lot of modifications it can do so like
this thing here has a trigger so what
that's gonna do is it's gonna shoot the
next thing well it's gonna ricochet yeah
you use this to ricochet but you all I
kind of use it to do all kinds of other
things so like for a way to put this
blonde here it's this way I put this
bomb here and now if I shoot somewhere
it's gonna hopefully do the bomb out of
a bomb and possibly kill me okay so like
you can essentially like screw it up for
yourself as well always yeah you are
there's like there is friendly fire for
yourself yeah that's game okay well it's
firm a dead can't can you ricochet a
shot off a wall and then eventually hit
yourself on I say today I think you can
do it okay yeah but we don't have for
the Bombers like the explosions killing
it and sure there's other things to kill
you there's a lot of things they'll kill
ya nothing about killing this guy he's
Connor is good so ever you pick one of
these this is kind of interesting it
changed the game in lots of ways he's
like now this will allow me to edit
wants everywhere so I don't have to get
on to this place to edit
once you get out of here this thing
collapses and you can't get back and
then you get to the next level okay and
so for example here like here's some
materials so this is kind of outer and
here's here's a dude who's gonna shoot
fireballs at me
yeah so if he if he hits that it's gonna
react also I'm gonna try to do this and
kill him with the barrel but his their
blood is also lava so that's no good all
right and you're making this very hard
for everyone right off the bat yeah so
there's a nasty rat there who's gonna
try to try to make the gunpowder react
you know that was gonna kind of set it
on fire okay but let's see you don't
want to see that you want to see that
balance yeah with the bombs
okay sure that's easier thank you I'm
gonna do it with the bombs where we try
to get an enemy ear do that for us okay
put like if we put a bomb there it's
gonna go and that you can see okay and
then it like creates a huge divot yeah
so now there's all this lava around here
okay hanging in there there's a bunch of
explosive things here these barrels here
filled with this nasty radioactive green
stuff but the good thing about the that
is like it you can neutralize it with
water okay and then because I think some
oil so this is on fire so what's
happening is it's generating steam
that's up here and then the steam is
compensating and you can maybe see it's
like water yeah okay wow there's a lot
of this whole level at each level I
guess the premise is that how reactive
it can be is part of the like what makes
noise to stand out from other games of
this style yes imagine yes it's very
much like there is a lot of like
interactions with like all those
physical properties so like all of this
like you can see this stuff here is kind
of like this coal stuff but there's like
difference here it's very subtle but you
can kind of see here that's explaining
it and then there's like gold because
cold in here if I can get that I can
pick up some coins
but so let's see goals to be a chest
you're gonna have a bit of a bit of a
dead end here but maybe we will bomb
away and so here's would I could have to
set this on fire
well while you're trying to make sure
you don't die I wanted to ask like can
you like walk us through like how
difficult it is to create worlds like
this that also makes sense for play
perspective because like I like I
mentioned earlier there I imagine there
are a lot of ways in which this can go
wrong were you oh yeah how challenging
is in what are those challenges when you
make a game like this well one of the
challenges is like it's it's easy to
think like when making something just
like highly emergent that all the
emergent stuff is kind of like good and
fun and interesting but the truth of the
matter is that you can also get like
sort of the game breaking emergent stuff
happening yeah and and depending on what
you'd kind of like think is game
breaking is a bit subjective but for
example when we start at the stream
because like all the enemies don't
really have like any they're not tied to
any area there was an enemy that was
gonna come and kill me at the very
beginning of the stream right yeah
there's a it was it like a tutorial
section like a very light Oriole section
there was already an enemy yeah Jesus
found its way back up there but then
what happened is the enemy tried to
shoot me but it there was like a lantern
that was unsealing and it killed itself
yeah the self on fire and killed itself
like well we were waiting I was like oh
damn I guess this is how reactive and
unpredictable
the world is so like one of the
attractions of noise I suppose is the
unpredictability and I suppose that's a
lot of the the attraction for rogue
lights in a broader sense and more so in
this game because of all the variables
that you are messing with but I also
wanted to ask about we we talked about
this a little bit earlier but I you draw
a lot of inspiration from spelunky Yes
Doctor and since then there's been a lot
of rogue lights that have kind of
thought about progression a little bit
differently rather than straight up
shutting you down once you die so I want
to ask like what it what is the
- like a sense of progression is it
purely this brogue element where you're
just like going run base and hopefully
make it to the end or how are you is
there a sense of rewarding players even
when they die like early in their run
well most of we're kind of like going
more with the sort of spelunky style so
there's not that much that's gonna stay
from the run around to run yeah there
are few things and we're kind of playing
around with how much of that to add I
don't know how much I can promise but
don't open there are a few things in
there that are and but they're kind of
also maybe bit and game hidden rf+ I'll
leave that up to you if you want to
divulge that stuff you know is your game
so good
we're not gonna make it there in time
but like okay let's pick not with that
attitude so one of the things they
modified here is I made my let's see if
this is gonna work okay
who's now by wand here next area so like
now it's gonna like meet this trail of
acid behind the right now without looks
dope and it's gonna generate this gas
and the gas is kind of flammable so this
acid business is it's actually really
sort of dangerous because it can pull me
down this time trying to shoot me let's
we can get him to set it oh I know all
right I think I also picked up a perk
where it just adds more blood so anytime
we kill an enemy there's gonna be enough
blood so that's why they're they're
leaking blood the blood is blood is also
like simulated so now you can see
they're covered in blood
oh yeah so it gets like on them yeah
across the world and it drips it along
the environment - yes we're currently
making a very violent game I mean pixel
art can be very expressive as I've seen
in many games that do the style
extremely well what even is that it all
seems like melt their bodies which is
like you really need to do that no but
it's like what you give your not do that
you think that was
you're saying your your a more moral
person yeah already already I already
got him so I don't need to add insult to
injury this guy this guy will freeze
like if his things will hit me it'll
freeze me frigid night yeah thank you
freeze all something brandy so you have
for example you hear you have a weapon
that leaves the gas trail Arthur oh nice
are there no essentially like bills
where I shall let you watch someone let
you all right let's see I hope I don't
get found
oh nice that thing ended up murdering
the ended up murdering background kami
can you kill those cuz you people ain't
a lot of love damage on I think they
they don't take that that much damage
from the thing from the acid
unfortunately there's also imagine it's
elemental stuff to like certain enemies
are damaged by these enemies are also
fighting each other we possibly really
good for me for anything boy murdered by
everyone oh my god oh we got away fine
I've got six HP oh it's perfectly fine
cool how do you look separate how guys
gonna yeah I get to the next area okay
we have two HP I don't get on get on
this bullet drop - oh my god yeah that's
all good
oh sorry I was like trying to ask a
question while you were like in the
worst possible yeah I just completely on
you yes you kill me
I'm just asking the question that's a
question you want to give it another run
we have a couple more minutes for you
here so dude
shoot you a quick one okay cool but yeah
what was I saying
Oh elemental stuff do different enemies
react differently to different types of
yes yes so that's a something you have
to consider it yes and you can use that
to your advantage so for example those
Firebug guys that have lava in their
blood and shoot fire
they they don't like water obviously so
like if you managed somehow to get water
like maybe get it done or it so you want
that like generates water even more -
yeah it's like murder them so I also
imagine there's an element of like
juggling what properties you give each
of your weapons depending on the
environment and then yeah fighting yes
yeah and it can help a lot like it for
you figure out be nice to see me not get
a single wand like a new generated game
so that I I know that it's like earlier
your one left leg ash trails yeah
they're like certain builds or weapon
combinations where like I can leave a
gash trail and then shoot it with like
like a fire weapon and then it'll like
not only does the gas spread but also
just turned into fire and just
completely obliterate like a bunch of
enemies at once yeah I mean you can do
like let's say I'm just gonna make this
homing so now I have homie
you can like for example make makeup oil
trail steak before Titus so now every
time I take damage I'm going to get
teleported into random place so what
that means is that's actually I'm giving
out two good strategies for like
speedrunning but unless you can use this
to like if you get also lips I don't
hire because then I'll catch all the
time so I'm teleporting around which can
blend we got the Sun yes we get we got
do it a shot yes I got it they can shop
it's hella forty to you right at the end
yes this is the way like you you wanted
to speedrun I'm giving you a speed run
here
I'm so glad we got that on stream that
was that was really fun oh this is this
would actually be good like now I'm also
like I'm invisible now but as soon as I
shoot or get stained I'm gonna get
visible this way we can sneak around a
bunch and we probably get this is much
more boring than doing the teleport I
draw fire
Lonnie okay let's nobody have picked it
up it's got different properties will
shoot differently I've got all kinds of
whoa already is that already attached to
it I don't know let's let's trudenta to
see what happens oh you signs and you
still have the teleportation so you're
like stacking a bunch of different
properties and abilities sniper guys
keep getting shot hopefully except Ella
for you in the end again let's try to
get to set on fire oh yeah there's oh
yeah I have these things I like holding
now so okay yeah like that's kind of
good and bad also at the same time ah be
Wow is there a rata like a like a like a
formula to the teleportation or is it
random or it's a bit random episode
because some like that's the ultimate
speedrun tactic it's got the
teleportation stuff just keep getting
get set yourself on fire yes there's
another one we can find but this is not
that this is gonna create this mist of
wood a little
what does that do this is it alive slow
down enemies or the blood will give you
right better chance of creating enemies
say smell better
covered in blood it's like oh snap we do
have about like a couple minutes left
okay for this I'll make it to the end
yes look oh no oh yeah the sniper guy I
just gotta know this Lodge okay as well
yes oh snap
mates again I made it to the end with 1
hp oh man this is a lot morning oh man
cool
yeah so I want to ask also do you have
any timetable in terms of release or
like what'swhat's the house development
going it's going pretty well but we're
still some ways off we're planning of
doing early access okay and hopefully
that's not it's gonna be hopefully at
some point alright but I we haven't
announced anything and we don't want to
announce before I kind of know we're
gonna make okay cool yeah
I understand that but uh yeah Petre
thank you so much for joining us that
was Neeta you can check that out on
where well how do you are you doing like
Kickstarter's or we have essentially we
have a steam page so you could wish list
it there or yeah follow us on our
website and we have a Twitter that we
update and put gifts of the game there
we go okay so let's n o ITA nota and
check that out if you're interested so
again thank you for joining me and then
we'll be right back we're gonna switch
swap out guests for a second and we're
gonna come back with a black future 88
so stick around for that
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hi we're back we got more games to show
it's the indie mix and we're showing off
a bunch of independent games great games
that are up and coming and we have
swapped out guests and now I have Don
and Zack here showing off black future
88 which is another game we showed off
last year and I imagine you have a lot
more new stuff to show know some high
level game player it's the same thing
it's the same thing we all are I touch
it and stay on the Shelf it's all good
cuz if you missed it last year black
future 88 is a rogue light
side-scrolling combat base game
it's pretty wild I was playing a little
bit last night so I can get a feel for
it kind of understand what I'm getting
into but uh yeah Jack's gonna be on the
controls over here while Don and I'm
gonna narrate the experience and it's a
religious experience less work for miles
so I'm all good all right so give us a
for those who don't know what black PJ
is can you give us the rundown of course
so uh black free trade is a synth Punk
action roguelike drug fuelled nightmare
fever dream where you only have 18
minutes to live - before your heart
explodes and in that time you need to
climb and murder a living tower filled
sky melt it's a it's intense I was
wondering that sky Melwood Sky Mall is
the name of the tower okay so we're
gonna do a special run today we're gonna
play old power just because I think he's
cool okay and that's kind of [ __ ] all
right
so Zak's gonna jump himself on to the
murder train
sick there we go I'm gonna go murders
some towers it's a it's a revenge
suicide mission to avenge humanity okay
begin takes place in an alternate
version 1988 after a nuclear catastrophe
post apocalypse yeah but you know it's a
post pre-apocalypse retro TV show yes
you know it's very specific yeah
apparently I was watching the intro it's
like no one keeps track of time yeah or
it might not actually be 1988 it could
be ten years after that the the actual
time period they stopped keeping track
of time after 1988 because that was just
like it's almost like the bcat division
so it's it's but the technology is still
stuck in 1988 yeah aesthetic is very 80s
synth wave like yeah simp Uncas yes so
it's a you know a lot of analog sense of
a lot of analog Simpsons sounds design
too and so exactly playing old power
which is actually a kind of a secret
character but if you think it's cool
held down and yeah old old power
actually he's old because it's in his
name so he actually had the last time
away oh wow yeah it's yeah so the timer
is in the top left and I was wondering
what that was about and I was like okay
so um each run is limited yeah sorry
yeah once you get one explore a little
bit more yeah I'm eating this but yeah
you know old man over here yes yeah what
15 minutes yeah yeah he's only older by
a little bit I have an identical twin
acting
but we joked that on the youngest my
career by statement okay
yeah it's kind of bad but oh you rate
your hon oh so dashing is the main
mobility mechanic in the game and it
starts out just like a really good
defensive move but as you kill wardens
for the bosses in the game you can
weaponize your - yeah gonna make it weak
just like
quickness and expedite all snap yeah a
giant beam thank you you can do a lot
with it yeah you can go through walls go
through platforms yeah so there's a lot
of tricky stuff you can do in terms of
combat and getting away from enemies via
approaching them yeah it's it's a really
fast pace and once you go in on an enemy
you really have to act on it it's
similar to kind of hotline Miami where
we're enemies we actually like them so
severe and yeah so it's everything about
the game just encourages you to play
fast and aggressively says act left a
little bit of money on it on the ground
and as you as you leave stuff on the
grounds that you're playing a roguelike
but so is the tower the tower is alive
and it will pick a buffs for itself
yeah and it might poison the rain and my
ascend hunters out after you which
really come powerful
great trips up great traps and that
might be what the player wants because
you know hunter always drops a good
weapon so you can actually kind of jack
up your starting power level if you just
draw the hunter really fast and yeah I
said you can also use time as a currency
you can is that kind of oh yeah yeah you
can trade them like a minute to get yeah
like a power that correspond yeah and so
oh oh oh I'll kill you yeah no it'll
kill you kids got a feed on your blood
bank your help right it's gonna kill it
you do get help
yeah oh yeah so that that was a drone on
the ground and in this game you can get
addicted to drugs and there's something
kind of neat that happens where you're
because in the retro 80s feature all all
drugs are kind of gasoline and petroleum
based oh yeah so once they're in your
blood you know your body actually
becomes flammable and that's that's the
real ha ha ha that's it that's kind of a
callback to annoyed sigh which we played
early yeah a lot like that um so you say
if you actually if you're addicted to
systems in the game and you put your
blood into a drone the drone actually
ends up addicted to drugs - and you'll
steal them and they'll steal health
packs sick and it's it's kind of a big
call out to a Robocop - oh ok
and - and so imagine you're like
sprinkling a lot of a lot of references
to sci-fi side of Roppongi yeah yeah I
always play it straight I go with this
darkest most heaviest series that tone
there's no liking or not a coup look out
buddy
set that gas side it oh yeah all right
so exact picked up the gas I did nail
smelter which
y'all got some wild name weapons but
also like the weapons themselves it
pretty why it's great to localize things
like you know the gas I did nail smelter
and it needs to fit in a box this big
apartment yes
so that gasps I think nail smelter
wherever you're aiming it'll leave a
little combustible gas um but then that
project out it fires as hot I said well
it'll come bus things that are
combustible and it'll create giant
explosions which are really player
hostile yeah they're awesome so things
that are more powerful Oh is present
more liability for Claire okay it's
about just giving the player more tools
and then a new they figure out like how
good they are yeah you know it's a good
time I was gonna ask about cuz when I
was playing I know it's like a sky melt
was had it's like ohmmeter yeah and a
bunch of icons next to that meter and I
was wondering what that was so you
mentioned that the tower itself is alive
in a sense and has its own properties
like you said that can rain poison or
something something so yeah and there's
like a lot of moments was there just
like a lot of stuff happening on screen
in terms like they aren't and looks like
yeah all the momentum like screen shakes
and there's like thunderstorms and I'm
like am I being damaged or like it's
just something I should worry about
there's this purely an aesthetic thing
like that it's a great question there
you know the game is overwhelming by
design
okay yeah that's reflected in the audio
in the gameplay and the individuals come
on so that's that's part of it and it's
up to the supplier to figure that out
yeah that is intentional Linux
it's chaotic it's like a 2-0 birthday
yeah you don't have to take the gun that
also blows you up at ease and run but
yeah you could yeah a lot a lot of the
difficulty in the game is elective so
the player can call it
so this black rifle is it's good it
actually uses your time to live as its
ammo source so every time you buy what
you'll lose a second of your deadlock
time you can look at this thing better
be good okay you can see the ammo
counter it's slowly ticking down yeah I
had a fire seeking projectiles there
aren't a lot of things that you acquire
seeking projectiles they know if I've
used that I know it's money man it's a
it's a lost killer so it's good okay so
you'll have it as your secondary in that
experience yeah but it's it's gonna set
you up for great difficulty if you don't
manage you like imagine yeah last night
I got it was like a it's like a laser
rifle that teleporting you to the NDS I
didn't I like that a lot yeah oh then I
know because taking the chair was like
so much momentum and like I'm trying to
get from place to place it's like yeah
in a way it's a built-in dodge yeah it's
absolutely you can you can use it to
dodge bullets fire like oh I fire and
all this night nail them and pass
through their projectiles yeah like I
would not take damage for entire swaths
of the room so yeah that was really cool
so I take the over court mm-hmm
so as you destroy wardens murder them to
avenge manatee you can you're offered a
way to upgrade your - but bosses also
offer their own signature box so you
dissipated goober Heim and achievements
first flooding enemy wants it so uh yeah
so it's it's just like a great tool set
in my your tool set keeps growing
through the run
yeah a lot of interesting stuff because
I was trying to like notice the timer
but also trying to like I want to see
what this weapon is on a mess with they
don't read the description yeah and that
that's part of the overwhelming design
that yes you know that there's enough
ways for the player to kind of fail and
succeed and that's a pickle which ones
toes are going to be right and it may
not be what they were expecting so damn
alright I won't ask about music though
I'm into like the 80s synth sim panca
specially like I dig drumming B I know
it's not the same but like like I want
someone maybe some of that but like who
makes the music ID man oh yeah I'm like
long frustrated indie musician and
starting making the game was actually a
music experiment Wow and it started out
as like you know the game was just this
this is really just a very advanced you
know consider the prototype just like
kind of kept growing it's a rhythm game
no but it really started out as like hey
I got my nuclear throne ripoff here and
then my John Carpenter ripoff here and
then they started like kind of change
and they middle like oh now this is like
really meeting it that's really cool so
yeah it is
and the game the music informs the
gameplay at times and in the game it
conceptually like that the music is the
voice of Steindl so it's rapturous it's
angry its aggressive joyous its meaning
yeah as he killed children
the wardens you know it's not not
pleased with that yeah music I imagine
like changes as you progress like it's a
different yeah is it reading too
reactive to what's happening in the
world
not really oh not really there's the
sweet tunes but yeah there's a few like
rare tracks that happen I like free to
zone there's just like a very low chance
that you'll get like this super chilled
out but a heavy track and I'm Cody yeah
I like that just as like a palate
cleanser because yeah I want people to
really have that one more run feeling
where everything is unique and you never
know yeah and that's good who works on
the art for this game you do anyway
right yeah that is xo1 it was in many
ways okay but it's got it so I found
Zach like on the internet because that's
just all I do right five people on the
Internet yeah fine no money no exactly
he's still in school he's where the
first person and brought onto the
project and um I like I just love his
stuff is super unique and like this is
like yeah there's you see stuff on art
station and like this is good technical
work yes yeah but then you see something
that speaks to you yeah and it's like
it's it's unique and it has an aesthetic
and like alright I'm gonna talk to this
person given whatever they want because
I like that it was well they probably
buy the fun I thought for profit yes
private 505 apart last night
yeah fonts and UI are my passion so I
yeah your boss killer
oh yeah we killed a bunch of bullets oh
you all you got the black nail huh oh
yeah the black nail also uses your time
to live oh snap so it's like the like
that a version of the gun that I was
talking yeah gonna be yeah and it'll
one-shot things that are later in the
game versus the night I always like fast
and savage yeah in a teleports you yeah
it it slows down or the power center so
the power center is really just a
converted golf club to turn in that got
turned into a lightning harvesting
facility yeah so people are right there
yeah it's a very dual-purpose venue um a
lot like my house I'd say go left
yeah do the Challenger let me hear it Oh
God oh so what's this um so it all
connect all the blood Lance love Lance
at Pelham hip no yeah there's these
series of challenge rooms in the game
where you know part of that elective
difficulty I mentioned is like give the
player chances to move faster but at
like great risk or liability so just one
of those challenge rooms you know
that'll always drop a weapon one of
these enemies but like it's a hard room
yeah it's a lot of horrible ain't got
any guide you got off unscathed also
yeah it looks like it dropped a weapon
we sometimes call the blood babe it's so
good it's it you know a rogue like you
know health is always at a premium and
health regen is always needs to be
stingy
that's one of the few ways to get it it
kind of works off from a secret combo
system to kind of let you regen health
so vapes your boat yeah yeah take your
own blood I can get behind that so babe
industry's got a advance somehow so yeah
well he's trying to really push that
poor guys are really suffering right now
buddy I can imagine that like in the
dark really dark future where like
people are harvesting blood it love it
yeah yeah there's like no but that's
like a premium fee yeah if you can
imagine like an accrued like an elite
class like yeah we rape the blood of
poor people oh my god dude so we can
work at like this can be seen at our
tech places it's like the player field
blood boys so then yeah futures dark man
yeah 2019 three guards here I'd say [ __ ]
man well so far so good
I mean black portrays it seems pretty
dope enough so yeah it's it's really got
that fever dream like an insanity Oh
already have there's a lot of melee
weapons in melee and Sam is just so good
I don't expect you to say that why dude
if you look at my Steam library have 500
hours of black future yeah it's like not
like forest there's plenty of bugs in it
I ever fix I just play it for fun yeah
maybe playing games at work oh the
baleen yard so you know baby
the whale so ya bailing it you know
baleen whale they're named that because
their baleen teeth they're not really
teeth they're like it's like a filter
like these tiny needles and so um the
whole like a humpback whale and a sperm
whale there are all types of baleen
whales because they have that built
right now and they cease as their teeth
has bullets that's cool so it's just
like a real life ammo hungry boss killer
body that's awesome are you okay that
looks bad I don't know I'm gonna need oh
man it's crazy it's like that if they
told you there's a hunter coming
sweating a little bit I'm just body oh I
did not see that coming I was laying
here oh so doing a little QA testing
guys says as you die you unlock
everything you unlock stuff as you die
and as you do that the gang starts out
simple and people will say oh it's like
cool contra but then they as you unlock
stuff and you get to like level 50 and
it's like oh here's a weapon that will
almost always kill me when I use it but
sick yeah that's like no there's like oh
but I kind of want to this is like very
contrary SH and that that's I think the
unlock system is where people are gonna
see if I code this game
because you you unlock stuff that's
actively player hostile you all lock
things like upgrades for the tower you
won't like the new hunters yeah they all
have qualities that you can kind of
exploit for your benefit but it's up to
you to master that so throw in a lot of
different variables that you can work
with yeah they always have like this
push and pull with the inventory because
that's like one of the most interesting
thing about road lights is like each run
I do want to do something different or
at least I want to experiment with
everything that this that a game offers
you until you find that one thing that
really resonates with you yeah favorite
gunner your favorite yeah yeah it's kind
of like the thing with dead cells is
like that that's what kind of people got
attached to yeah didn't run Swift that
game and and I think what's really cool
is that because you unlock stuff that
really changes the nature of combat and
changes the nature of play the game is
constantly evolving so it already has
that procedural generation layer like a
lavallois
procedural whatever and then developers
but then the game is evolving like
underneath your feet and like it
you're always uncertain of like well
what is this like as it is this good
from your bad for me and how do I make
yeah so that that's the thing I really
like so what are you what are you what's
your end goal though like each with each
run you try and make it as far as you
can before the time runs out or your
actual time oh yeah burn down sky melt
before behind ones out where is it say
you have 18 minutes to live to play the
game but it will probably takes the tip
eat it takes quite a bit more than that
so there's a lot time management I think
that at the very high end something's
very good at the game because it's a
very skill focused game yeah
they could play much longer oh I didn't
actually do this so there's a shortcut
in the tower are you gonna do it you're
gonna steal from them who would steal it
steal it you want to see some Elmo sees
a chick without yes and I have to fight
three hunters and I rewards are real
nice though
yeah but you can either buy the weapon
or you can just take it and then take
that than that yeah yeah get paid buddy
oh the autumn
it's a savage world out here and our
black beauty but he's he's taking a
shortcut in the cistern we're all the
shitty drugs are made the water is just
like disgusting I imagine so much more
you take shortcut but it's a much more
hostile vapor smells already gonna
you're gonna die I work business my
success rate with the vapor smelter is
about 1 1 % it's not bad
well we are we got a couple minutes left
so I'll another let's make it happen
yeah that's making that was me
in there oh yeah yeah so I mentioned
like that how it works yeah like that
combustible gas and then you collide
with hot things but what the vapor
smelter does is this a hot beam at the
end but it generates gas where from your
weapon so if you use it on something
that's too close to you it's gonna
itself detonate and probably kill you as
we saw so it's really just this high
liability boss killer weapon it's so
good yeah and you end up in a in a room
like the sister and like he was in and
it's like oh these are all tight common
rooms and you end up with like the
weapons that drop there are all like
really heights here which means that
they're really dangerous but everything
in the game should feel like you're
you're handling like a loaded gun that
has knives and yes you're not just like
in danger in terms enemies one of the
things like you're using and like like
you said the tower itself is dangerous
so everything is a sharp object in there
everything counts okay cool
all right man I think that's as much
time as we had I think we picked off at
11:28 now it's 11:48 oh it's alive in 20
minutes but yeah there's a lot more to
black future 88 I imagine so all the the
Battle Royale version I think will be
called Black Series right here 99 so uh
they say when you name something put a
bunch of numbers at the ends and it's I
think that's got more numbers than
that's a cyberpunk game oh boy the
numbers are hired so it must mean is but
wait a minute
okay all right man yeah thank you for
stopping by thank you 3488 yeah dawn Zac
it's been a pleasure
have a great GDC yeah I imagine there's
a lot of things going on for you guys
there's a lot of things going on for us
here at GameSpot and if we got a lot
more for all of you watching because we
got four more games coming up there very
good yeah
there are everyone here at the indie mix
is in support of each other independent
games about uh independent game
developers making some dope stuff so
stick around cuz we got more to show off
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
welcome back to GameSpot's any mix
livestream I'm here with the goose boys
from house house because oh boy we got a
treat for all of you out there I know a
bunch of you want to see this game
untitled goose game
they're here to show it off everyone
introduce yourselves I'm Jake I'm Nick
and I'm Stuart and these are the goose
boys from house house and they're
showing off untitled goose scheme so who
wants to give a quick rundown of what
untitled goose game is oh okay it really
is just a game where you play as a goose
that's kind of the start and the end of
it yeah it's it's as low stakes as you
imagine all right and you're gonna be a
seer you be on the controls right yeah
so let's let's jump into it let's seize
this game and action that's physics dog
some cute oh this game is really cute
I got enamoured by cute things no I love
my cat she's beautiful and I would like
a pet goose that would be dope but uh
let's see
okay sure sure yeah well ask you if you
want yeah after this all right so walk
me through what you're doing here so I
can do whatever I want like any anything
that goose could do I feel like once
once you
for example goose has wings that they
could plan a picnic you're sprinting
around any patch of grass you see in
this game you can go to massive open
world oh boy okay so you go around
you've got a little nick can wiggle that
around a bit cool man
all right first the first time I saw
this game when it was first revealed I
was like what if this is like a hitman
game but you're a goose instead you just
like sneak around stealing things
absolutely
uh-huh I'll see habitude to-do list
never thought you do this this case we
got to you probably didn't know this bit
sometimes to do this Fergus beautiful
handwriting awesome so that first goal
is to get into the gut and okay
then some uh things like getting this
grant oh ok guys so it's stealing the
gun skippity we're trying to introduce
the groundskeeper I know very curious
decent bids all right hunk no hide that
does that what he gets do okay oh they
know that's their quacking it's uh it's
like ya know ever this season
investigate what was that noise so they
don't know is a good yet age it's just
the good know it's a honk yeah okay so
what to get caught they just like yeah
um sick objective complete
so you just that's it kind of put up
with you he doesn't like you yeah he
doesn't really hate you oh yeah no it's
just effective life and there's there I
guess in the world okay all right so you
got objectives ruining some carrots
sesemann why does dig deep down getting
into the gun okay yeah says it next to
get them wet sure all right you got it
you got to drag him over to the lake I'm
at yeah yeah let's go through button
mechanics sick
yeah actually get him over the plate but
which I did start you know Ryan said a
little check for him mess with is a
sprinkler hmm
oh yeah here we go oh that's messed up
it's not it's not true me in there
because a goose doesn't really
understand the concept of getting wet or
anything I don't know oh yeah of course
your mama's a kind of excuse by the
virtue of being and we had animals
doesn't understand uh-huh oh okay
so they got wet mm-hmm what you got next
on your to-do list children there's a
few things firstly you're just kind of
mess with him full of stuff head it up
kids pumpkins oh man yeah you your mess
up his entire garden you know how hard
he works for us I don't I'm good this is
just but yeah look they will really
exist just for me to kind of mess up as
I say fit where does a Kenny I would
speak to the inspiration for this game
like where did it come from why geese in
particular so like we tell this story a
few times before but literally it comes
from one stock image of a goose which we
thought was very funny and pushed it in
a like group chat saying oh let's making
that this this funny image and
everything that's happened since then it
just kind of comes from that oh it's
like two years of work well I didn't
like image with still like a watermark
over the top of it from like stop photos
don't come or whatever oh we wanted to
make like a game with a nice 3d
character you could pop it around hmm
had a bunch of different birds you could
do so thank you running and flapping
your wings and ducking and still it's
sort of physical physical things to do
in this funny buddy uh-huh and what kind
of looking around what what fit that
bill the best and the goose kind of just
all right this perfect hit the body Dan
yeah it's kind of like it's a fun animal
class but it was also like a fun animal
for us to make it was like of all the
ideas we had that was like the most
exciting that's the one stuff yeah
imagine imagine being able to make a
little goose that you can pile around oh
and especially just with people's
reactions to case like socially
culturally they're a bad animal for some
reason yeah yeah at all it's really
loaded people have strong opinions of
that gays yeah all right speaking friend
steal his keys if it's built because oh
that's your next yeah that's like
excellent yeah yeah so try and wait till
he's distracted a little bit so we can
kind of got a sneak up on him he's aware
of you but ant Lane
yeah you can't escape the stuff it's not
like he's gonna catch you and put you in
goose jail or something
you know but you still need to remain
unseen sometimes like if you're gonna
steal some cheese oh oh god oh oh oh
he's gonna snatch him back yeah yeah
I'll definitely try I am just losing
pork I can barely run we got do this
skis now yeah I need his keys to us yeah
that's the key for that game ah sweet we
can't give them back but maybe we'll
just leave them gifting at all put the
radio a second really mad oh boy it's
this lizard
it's a plane ragtime that's kind of like
this fella sympathy's oh yeah this one
okay how about ragtime - hit it
that's what salesmen get hyped oh
goodness there you go come on man I'll
cut some jams it's a little quiet in
there yeah fading this keys so you like
it did you have to do anything with this
keys can you do anything else can you
open up the shed start messing up and
stuff i deprived him of the caves but
they useless to you yeah pretty much
everything you've taken today yeah wait
this is not having it is the only event
yeah yeah yeah
it seems very therapeutic yeah it's like
it's serene it's quiet it's also yeah
it's messing with people can be can be a
therapeutic experience I imagine that's
worth it imagine this where the
inspiration came from besides the stock
image of the person this is like an
outlet for people who want to like
low-level harass people just like you
mess their [ __ ] yeah and so yeah the
thing is like we just got off playing a
black future 88 yeah after you're done
with that game and you just want to
chill out cuz I guess oh there's a lot
going on that yeah yeah
decompress right yeah after a stressful
day or stressful game I mean I suppose
this could be stressful if you're trying
to like get on your to-do list what is
next thing it to me is actually no we
good
this may be the most cryptic one of the
game we can make him wear a Sun Hat okay
but let's do better that's them yeah
let's put that rake in the lake to rake
in the lake yeah a little big this goose
must be strong if you can carry a yeah
rake with his mouth we we play kind of
fast and loose with oh sure how much
physical force the goose can exert in
the world
well Oh homeboys gonna mess up their
beak oh yeah
get your shoes had a few distractions is
generally a good way to do it
yeah well you still see me trying him to
wait to take off his Sun Hat or get
we're trying to play ok break in the
lake yeah
as he puts this Jamo and there we go no
hug
did you get a can you get him wet again
will that distract them I don't know
okay oh he's walking
oh yeah good good good he's not oh look
what does he care about more is his
character's break his it most about
whatever you are doing
oh it's there that's what that like just
keep them G he gets startled from your
from your quacks - it loud alright I
think yeah
buuuut of a goose you get startled as
well
hell yeah there we go yeah this is going
straight in the lake wow this is this
game is more sinister than I thought I
was all I cute cuddly or whatever raping
the lake all right
trick a sandwich yeah yeah yeah you've
been uh I thought you're gonna eat it
like you've been having a lot of words
say it like to treat yourself
it might H be back oh okay I slip this
little shoe pinion oh you really messed
someone's day up
that's a savage can you do anything with
the lawnmower no really that's move for
him okay like we turn to turn it on like
different got up on the starter and
start yanking it he's planted just flat
out back again which he loves how would
you get him to wear his Sun Hat though
so if we could find a Sun Hat which we
can reach that about how did that grasp
kind of look at it that's about it look
longingly um I put his boots back to it
in place hey put his yeah he's
constantly kind of tidying up after you
he just wants a nice little italy-- yeah
it's the opposite of what you would yeah
it really is the kind of aiya hiddens
Gardens
it's the dichotomy of the kind of wild
against man's desires huh that's a
pretty deep commentary to me yeah yeah
if we get his hat off him we could
probably make it oh okay yeah you steal
his hat or get him to take off his hat
so you put on the other one should climb
up the hill and check it that's JIT oh
yeah I don't mean that's a good way yeah
he's probably this what am I good yeah
it was a little run I'll see you guys
motivated boots and a bits of missing
that's pretty distressing and all cuz I
hit them in the head
there's no idea it it's bitter ah damn
he's gonna other boots be fine in terms
of the state of this particular build
but like hello how close is it to like
how far are you into the full
development of this game
um so this build is just a demo of this
which you'll be the starting area at the
game okay and then we've got a few more
areas like several more after this that
we've been working on kind of slowly in
the background finally alright so when
the game is ready you'll have several so
I have it's more like this yeah of more
things to do on your to-do list yeah
yeah yeah yeah longer list yeah the
games
in this small town so you're gonna get
to visit different areas around town
yeah there's more people and kind of
different different configurations of
people it's a deep lore which means it
and some people are afraid of the CUSO a
little bit tougher oh yeah no throw it
in the lake it's okay yeah in the lake
you wouldn't want to wear it if once you
throw in the lake so it's true you'll
wear it Sun Hat eventually oh man oh
poor guy that's a really nice hat you're
just gonna toss on the water yeah
really show it I want him to see it
going like ok still got it
this is messed up no no if you want it
you want it I got it
there it is he's like God dagnabbit my
damn hat believe it oh he still wants it
though that's nasty
slip is dripping wet happy just take it
in snatch it right out of his hand you
do that right yeah
[Music]
no never possibly city now he's thinking
about the rake to put my leave
oh yeah of course now that we've led him
down to their lake he knows about all
these stuff that we've dumped in he is
sensing it isn't really gonna go in the
water I don't know waiting honest he
doesn't like getting wet still I mean
you are doing a fuss you already
completed that objective so if you got
it back it's all good
yeah we don't mind now it's wet that's
what's important yeah it's mainly about
making things wet sweet I'm all about it
picnic does one of your other to-do
lists yeah yes I have a picnic maybe the
most complicated one we just got to
assemble his different things oh oh you
got a so you already had like the
sandwich yeah Apple which you've tossed
into the lake no bananas we have the
fish that Mehcad yeah now you gotta like
pluck from his garden to finish your
complete meal let's gonna put a/c yeah
there we go
yours yeah you put that hat on boy
that's what he likes sweet likes to
cover up his his wall good home I
understand actually I don't
yeah Oh what else you need for a picnic
uh oh give me that pumpkin that you just
put back oh yeah how complete of a meal
are we working with here I don't know if
anyone would happen if anyone described
this is like a good big dick to have I
don't know anyone brings like a whole
pumpkin thermos radio carrot and I'll
say carrot Jam carrot carrot and Jo I we
you you picked up that jar of jam yeah I
don't know where I live that yeah it's
great some of it down okay we're gonna
make it big
oh you got to put on the blanket that's
Heather okay cool yeah that's what yeah
all right see if we can uh yeah I'd love
for you to complete the picnic yeah sign
off here hopefully we can do that in
time
sweet run what's up to speed run yeah
you see them through some stress okay
you see this game being speed speed Rand
I would I would absolutely yeah this
game to be I can see that
all the time it yeah definitely like we
go to put in a timer or something at
least you got it like facilitated so Oh
Jeff dad pro strats didn't like oh
that's a basket that was a suitcase yeah
tripping okay um better get both halves
of the sandwich - yeah sandwich doesn't
count on misses it's one pointer it's
soggy a sandwich fish doesn't care
yeah uh yeah I throw bread into the lake
when you're not supposed to may eat it
up I don't know if they're ducks turkeys
geese sweet what else if history we need
a thermos Jan let's see what else am i
curious about when it comes to this game
there's a there's a lot going on here
wait where's a oh yeah I got the thermos
to write what it is all the really I
like huh just drinking that I think you
shut it up how close together the trick
of the radio is he'll hear it can i
press the maps you're gonna get a wet
nurse to the law what ran check it in
the light
yeah you'll hear it and far away so
he'll come running
it's got to keep kiting him yeah this is
a guys it's basically like an MMO yeah
yeah so I'm like a heavy classroom you
don't get the radio with it it's gonna
get busted that's okay check it in that
how much time we got left drinking I
think we have about five more minutes
and get some Jam you think you can do
that yeah I plead that picnic in five
minutes
sweet
what do you guys think in terms of you
think about release window at all or
database yeah okay yeah sweet and it's
coming for a PC switch and Nike yeah I'm
at okay cool
sweetie this is yeah this is would be a
nice tranquil experience on a very
hectic bus ride I suppose yeah yeah it
was very nice getting it up and running
on the switch like the fellow yeah yeah
you got it
you know what was it like working mom is
it and much different from like making a
PC build or journey since I can give
them terms like working on the switch
hey I don't know any insight necessarily
like that the main fun thing is just
like you get to take the game to play
yeah it's been like a long day in the
office and you get gets his son and sit
outside and still get to play the goose
yeah make your own picnic yeah yeah
sweet
yeah tell me how long you in terms of
like how many different to-do lists
you're gonna complete how long are you
thinking this final final game would be
that's been okay at this point mm-hm
probably not ready to say an exact
number just in case it changes a little
bit yeah okay now then yeah maybe the
general idea is just like you have a
kind of list like this speech narrator
you go to varying degrees of challenges
oh yeah yeah some of them get more
complicated there it is we done did it
enjoyments good can we do CAG let's
let's enjoy the picnic a little bit
let's see what we got does they do it
right goodies take dick they call that
yeah got a sandwich you got Jam
alright now let's check out what's
happening with them a friend that
groundskeeper they should invite him at
least yes you can do them store all the
[ __ ] let's tell him about it yeah steal
his hat again
[Music]
yeah I tried I could get him to the
picnic yeah knocking his keys was that
the last week of July sergeant
yeah I'll get the last one through this
door yes sure it's good cool thing
probably takes miss people bit longer to
get everything right yeah he's played a
few times before yay wonderful hit the
groundskeeper that's my pumpkin dough
and then now I'll just spend the next 10
minute putting on Jenny get the yes oh
cool
lock the gates yeah oh he didn't pick up
his keys yeah you lock him out of his
own house like this can jump ending up
at that point that's the best come on
this dude's got this is quick let's
watch them is let's see what he does in
the next couple seconds here I hope
you'll I know really showing situations
just like yeah they come up sometimes
yeah how do you how do you - can any of
you speak - like what it's like to
program an AI - I mean I think out way
of designing this AI probably isn't all
that similar to other people's in that
we just try and make them as kind of
aloof as possible but then I really know
anything that's going on like constantly
just bamboozled by the way oh yeah
that's a good word yeah it's a good way
to put it but he is funny like this is
this game I think originally wasn't
about AI it when we first started making
it it was about like being his character
and it really done it like it kind of
gradually evolved into like a stealth
game right like with those kind of
mechanics really organically yeah you
just needed this person to play all the
pranks on yeah - a news about what was
happening to them - funnier it was yeah
and that just led us to use more and
more stealth sorts of things like and
the more they react to you like they are
yo Mira in this game oh yeah
oh yeah everything you do they
everything you mess so somebody trying
to lead up
because it's bad to someone yeah yeah
yeah yeah being bad and avoid no not
actually that fun yeah a seance quinces
it's like yeah whether we put the hat in
the lake before that's like yeah you can
see that angry yeah expression that's
the real reward yeah I so question for
you then yep you still want a Pickers uh
well you know my cat's fine she messes
up enough of our stuff so I can it'll
keep you Sammy
yeah yeah y'all saved me from having pet
coos so I thank you for that yeah so
that's uh that is a bit of untitled
goose game from house house thank you
fellas for stopping by is there anything
else you want to say maybe for maybe the
doubters out there and we're not feeling
untitled goose why cool you have a glass
words for uh for us here thanked out
yeah that's fine all right he said later
this year yeah yeah okay cool and that's
again that is untitled goose game if
that tickled your fancy you should tech
check that out because it's coming out
later this year thanks fellas thank you
yeah all right and we're gonna be back
with more on the way we got I think
three more games to get through for the
any mix here on GameSpot so stick around
for that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and we're back with GameSpot's any mix
livestream I'm Michael Heim again in
case you are just tuning in I am joined
by Cyril and Arno from da mu and we're
gonna be playing some dark devotion now
this is game this game is gonna be it to
be a little bit heavy on the matically
and gameplay wise I know you could you
were giving me the rundown on what
exactly this is so for all the folks out
there can you repeat yourself I didn't
mean to walk or have you walked me
through the entire thing just to have
you say it again but yeah let's yeah
tell me about dr. motion so yeah and
Doug devotion so as you can see on the
screen it's it's not a road like it's
not a Metroidvania it's an action RPG so
you play that Templar you should sent to
that temple in asakusa basically
religion is really important in devotion
both for the the scenario but as well
all in the gameplay there's a lot of
mechanics going on for the religion part
of the game so you're sent in this
Templar in this temple sorry for for
that second mission which is basically
save your god you don't really know at
the beginning of the game what is
exactly the temple what is exactly your
mission yeah your place in the world is
kind of something you want ravel it's
really secretive and you there's a big
lower in the game yeah and you but it's
not given to you you know it's not easy
to have access to that level but
everything in in the weapons description
you can find clues pretty much
everywhere in the game about what's
going on basically yeah so alright all
of you out there I know y'all gonna want
to kill me for making this comparison
you said it yourself though is a lot of
inspiration from Dark Souls yes yeah
it's interesting because the team
developing the game so the game is named
Vernon workshop workshop a French young
French studio and what's interesting is
that the first when they started working
on the project and none of them have
played duck sauce and really yeah after
afterwards when everybody told them yeah
your game really looks like the Axl's
they okay yeah effect yeah apparently
looks like mussels but alright yeah of
course there's there's a me the ambiance
how would you say that in English yeah
in the atmosphere yeah yeah because you
were talking about how lakpha matically
it's about like religion and there's a
lot of like different sects of these
really like religious island say cults
but like they're all like vying and it's
basically to to cult okay yeah so yours
and be the others and so it's a bit
complicated try to explain everything
it's mysterious actually throughout the
game you'll feel some aspects of the
lore as you progress through the game
yeah it's not it's kind of implicit so
we have kind of left over yeah game the
Lord can even be hidden in the weapons
and stuff like that yeah so that was
thing about that's how Dark Souls kind
of communicates a lot of its lore so I
mean making the compared it's a fair
comparison to make but also in the
gameplay I noticed that it's very it's
it's not like you know when I when I
look at 2d side-scrolling games I almost
like at this point I think of like dead
cells and how how fast that game moves
but here it's more slow and deliberate
where it's a lot more like a traditional
action RPG you know I have to think
about like moves and like okay this move
is gonna be like a bunch of frames so
like I better time it right yeah nothing
is freeing them game you have to make
all decision and you have to be sure
with it yeah yeah and you have to commit
yes you want to do a swirl attack you
have to come into it yeah if you're not
sure you're gonna die yeah and you're
gonna die a lot in that motion yeah
okay that's kind of what I notice here
too is that yeah this slow thing because
I'm good a bit later yeah no I actually
had the conversation with the developer
from noida or doing noise oh and then I
was talking about like hey you got shot
like this is your own game you gotta be
you gotta be good at it he was perfectly
fine though it's a wonderful fella
we're only publisher so we have the
right to be yeah yeah yeah Van Allen
yeah
so yeah that's a really good yeah so uh
Hibernia yeah yeah can you speak a
little bit more about where they are
what they do is that talk about a little
bit earlier yeah it's uh it's three
people studio so it's a French studio
they're 25 years old they actually don't
have a video game series so there's a
one that the the Diploma in actually he
has a master's in biochemistry
okay why not another one did sociology
and I don't remember the third one but I
mean it's really something Todd yes
really stuff thought they very like the
spirit of like an independent game yes
definitely we revealed we did three dev
Diaries for oh okay with the game and on
the third one they talk a little bit
more about the background and what they
did and it's interesting to see how with
that that knowledge of making video
games just by patient and patients as
yeah you can make something really great
such as this one and you're like you're
not Thai I imagine that coming into that
they they're not tied to the conventions
they may have learned in the past or
something so it's I imagine it's gonna
be like a rough process but what they
will get out of it eventually as you can
see here is we something kind of unique
and a little bit more it has that spirit
of like an independent game I guess you
could say so the dev Diaries where can
you find those that's on YouTube yeah
okay you hold up devotion that idea okay
yeah be definitely interested in
checking that out and it's interesting
because those guys tell us also that
that's a
executioner also will try to collect on
I have the worst weapons I would eat all
along but we have spells here so yeah
maybe you can talk a bit about the games
while you try to beat the boss yeah idea
thank you
so yeah basically what I love about this
game is that content is super rich you
have tons of different weapons of in
each weapon has its own fighting style
for example right here I have a spare
and normally for example with the sword
and shield I can block attacks but with
the spare I can just dodge really quick
so I can get away from the enemy and
then oh try to appear simply the yeah
with a lot and also there's like a
different range
according to weapons there is some magic
so here I have a book that enables me to
throw fireballs
thanks to my faith and so you have you
have lots of different mechanics for
combats and it's super interesting the
bosses are really well designed as well
you can see that this guy once I get
half of his life
you get changes his work set right gets
faster yeah music changes as well you
have more than 25 bosses in the game and
they're all super well design it's real
pleasure to discover them and try to
understand how to beat them I'm
right there in the game you have a lot
of different systems as well like the
skills for example when you kill an
enemy you get you regretted some faith
from your god there is the regular face
that enables you to open the chest open
doors get blessings and stuff like that
but you also have the corrupted faith
which enables you to unlock certain
skills you have a lot of different
skills that goes from the classic like
increasing your critical hit ratio to
like creating lightning balls when you
attack with the sword or stuff like that
and so you have to discover all these
different skills every time you die you
get back to the hub this is the demo so
basically it's not the regular game it's
just to show different parts of the game
but basically when you die you go back
to the hub you can choose new skills
also during the game you can drop some
blueprints for weapons so you definitely
unlock some new possibilities each time
you start a new run and and yeah what
else you also have quests that are given
to you at the shelter where you where
you spawn when you die those question
able you to again unlock different
objects different skills so basically
there's a lot to do in dark devotion a
lot to explore everything is level
designed so all stop procedurally
exactly so basically there's there are
different paths so everything is level
designing but every time you die you
have different choices you can try again
the same run you just did because you
learned about it and you learn about the
different enemies their patterns and
stuff like that or you can choose a new
one that you unlock during your first
pass for example but the cool thing is
wearing the game is that every time
every time you change a room you
go back yeah so your only option is to
go further basically okay so in this in
a way it's a bit like you said it's not
procedurally generated but anyway these
are like different stages to a much
larger world yeah okay so you can finish
the game once and redo the game a lot of
time and play really completely
different yeah so it's like branching
paths yep and with all their bosses with
other fights other enemies other weapons
the game is really super generous so
there's all that Oh in terms like
punishment from like dying or in terms
of just content you know there's oh okay
right weapons
yeah terms of spells and tons of secrets
and tons of mechanic as well so yeah we
talked a little bit about the faith so
like I said earlier the Legion is really
an important part of the cake but yeah
makes no it's impressive but yeah yeah
exactly the same I mean you can you can
put it through thanks third time's a
charm we got yeah sure only one
believing that but yeah religion is
really important so there's the that
faith and then we talked about so that
you can talk some stuff with it but
there's also that kind of rewarding
mechanics so what's the name in English
you got depending on the way you you
play your God can reward you or your
company
okay issue so with a baby is extremely
extremely synchronizing game curses
right alright so so what those play is
like stat buffs and debuffs or different
abilities that kind of give and take
like your if your God doesn't like the
way you play you can punish is you can
punish you so it's cold yeah but very
few likes the way your if you likes your
deposition yeah well you and it's going
to be so how does that actually like
factor in like in terms of as a player
how do I know that that's happening is
it there's like yeah the stats or is it
like yeah story based there's an effect
on your character you can see a special
effect on me I don't when that happens I
think a bit earlier you got pierced
while hiding we are in the exploration
phase yet okay so so yeah you'll be
aware because because you'll be you can
be slower that's something that can
happen or you can be poison as well yeah
it's just depending on what she what you
did and and yeah in terms of content
like we said there's a lot of bosses a
lot of a lot of weapons and it's really
interesting because it's not it's not a
rod-like yeah it's not run based but
still like I said earlier you can replay
the game there's a really great
replayability and of course you'll play
a lot a good part of that for you yeah
but I mean you're when you killed us you
you're really happy about it
you deserve your way and that's why it's
every decision it's important and but
when you make the right ones to really
have it's rewarding yeah it's really
great that dodge at the last minute you
know BAM did that last phase is like
tough cuz you can teleport like two or
three times and like you don't know what
he's gonna like stop yes and actually
attack like this is demo so you don't
have the best stuff right at the
beginning okay
you should have open the chest first
because yeah but when you do when you
arrive at the post the first time you
see you have a pretty good stuff because
you did the whole exploration phase what
you can ask that yeah so you have more
time till I get here you're working with
like the barrier that closed like in the
pyramid you know but yes so basically
the good thing is like you do a whole
run then you discover our bus usually
you die the words but the thing is like
the weights level design and game design
it's like there's no place for
randomness and you can only blame
yourself if you if you don't manage to
be reverse yeah so it's doable I mean
like some of guys that are at our QA
department they managed to beat the game
is like just like the worst weapons in
the game you know just to try it that it
works it it's pretty cool but yeah
basically you learn through your
explorations of the temple you discover
Lorre discover new techniques you
discover new weapons and then when you
die you say okay so this bus was pretty
quick so maybe I should switch out
shield and a sword to beat him this gun
this bus was slow so maybe I can have
him quicker with a double handed sword
and stuff like that so there is a whole
strategic thinking every time you die of
like which skills I'm gonna use which
weapons I'm gonna use and why and you're
really the sensation of being more and
more powerful through each run because
your weapons get better
you
skills get better and your overall
actual skills like with the game your
reflexes and stuff they get better and
better so it's really about again like
the bosses are very diverse you have all
types of buses they're quite impressive
my hands are square sweating right now
half of the first time I played this
game from far that's it's always it's
always a bit stressing because it's you
know like yeah tweet fries this so yeah
I mean that's that's that's again like
when we started to see the game to play
with Hibernian there was already a lot
of deaths in the game but now the way
we've improved we did a lot of play
tests we did a lot of back-and-forth and
we came up to the final version that we
have now which is very nice they're
young very very great to play and
discover all the way the Lord has been
inspired by the Romantic era and also
the Adyar Allan Poe yeah I can see so
the universe is pretty cool it's very
dark you always feel threatened by
something there are lots of traps in the
games as well yeah I can't ask earlier
in your exploration phase yeah other
than like enemies like how about during
an enduring exploration like how much
more challenges get exactly oh boy and
yeah so you don't have a lot of life
usually you have life points you can see
Bob so the red is your life once and
above it the shields are your armor
points and yeah basically so right now I
know is only like five six hits and now
it just has one left okay so yeah your
limited terms like exact walking dodging
and when you explore you're always like
distension because when you lose one
hits and you don't know how long it's
gonna be until the next boss you know
like
so you're always very cautious about
what you do on the first runner at least
on then after this fifth seventh run
then it's easier you know where they go
and you know what's up but when it's the
first time you explore some some region
it's it's so often dark sometimes you
need to use some use of a hand to use a
torch or something exactly that's like
your I don't have a shield it's super
scary and and there's always this
tension because you don't want to to
face the boss with only one line yet you
know so it's it's there's always a
tension which is pretty nice yeah high
difficulty in games is kind of been uh I
guess I don't say no I would say recent
trend but like it's it's got it involved
yeah big time yeah so obviously like
judging from here this game wins on
difficulty yeah being a big learning how
to play the game getting your reflexes
right but once you get them I suck at
ducks
okay I can say the same so when I
started to play the game I loved the
universe and I love RPGs so that's
really why also we wanted to work on
that game but I started to say okay I
need to pass beyond like the difficulty
yeah and as it stood it's it's a bit
easier to master just really because you
have less dimensions to you have less
possibilities to handle right and so
it's more about like reflexes and
and dexterity but once you get it
straight then it's easy you know what
what to do you know where it goes so
it's challenging since it's not often
frustrating you know the way it was
designed so so yeah difficulty in that
game is kind of high but also this is a
demo so you start right away with the
bar yeah
again likes Parrish exploration phase
you can see that I didn't get hit a lot
because I know how to play the game as
well but yeah at the beginning is really
tough but it's nice as well because it's
flawless you know like you start again
at the shelter
you have the weapons you want to try
them so you do a new run during your new
run you're unlock new stuff as well so
it's always renewed and renewed
experience there is some randomization
of the items you can get in chests with
enemies and stuff like that so it's the
runs are never the same and there's also
always a new door a secret room that you
never discovered that will enable you to
even get more powerful and and be
different with yeah more easily yeah but
the difficulty curve yeah when you there
are four different worlds in the game
time you enter a new world it's like wow
okay so it's a new level yeah it goes
step by step and it's nice because it's
always challenging it's never like it's
something like okay I got the game it's
over like I can beat it's over way it's
always a bit more challenging always a
bit different as well yeah always new
enemies new different types of traps I
guess exactly you were to go with your
new styles for example some enemies with
sword and shield
they're like little goblins that are
really really weird and they they
they're super fast so with sword in and
shoot it's not very efficient the most
efficient it was the double dagger and
you're super fast and you go around them
so you should do a run and you know that
you're gonna encounter this again you
say okay I'm gonna equip before going
with that weapon and try to drop all the
weapons of different style in order to
be really when I am going to encounter
these so every time you die there is a
kind of preparation ritual where you go
to see the weapons miss you go to see
the game from the quest you get to see
different
characters from the game that will give
you hints about the law and how the game
goes and stuff like that
cool I think this will be our last
attempt yes since we are I'm gonna die
hey man you can do it yeah I'm sure the
folks back there in the control room my
coworkers my boys are wouldn't be okay
with going over time a little bit if we
can beat this boss here
so much pressure oh yeah man it's not
gonna happen
yeah pressured me too much cover my bad
what is in the second place use the
shield that's the best the best tactical
stuff I usually can bid him being easily
but man my boy Eric Tate down there in
the control room two loves these styles
of games so I want to hear what he has
to say once we once we are in the
transition phase of this live stream
because yeah he loves his Dark Souls
blood-borne type games yeah and it's so
satisfying when you're Peter goes yeah
yeah
this one is pretty challenging at the
center first one with is this the first
boss and no okay
although say like a hell of an
introduction so Christmas is way easier
the first is actually attached to a wall
so it doesn't move so when you get good
tries to eat you doing the first placed
on the second face basically like rip
his arm off starts like yeah and then
you move the wrong yeah so imagine like
what I mean it's well it's like you can
do a lot of creative things with the
pixel arts you know and just oh man well
I appreciate both of you trying at least
and I was almost Cyril Arno thank you so
much for yeah is there any last words
you got about dark devotion before we
sign you guys off yeah if she want to
learn more about the game
we already released three dev Diaries
where the team explained how they did
the production about the arts about the
universe of the game so if you want to
know more about the game just check
those out super interesting yeah and
yeah we can reach this the game on Steam
as well yeah it's already there and
learn about there are a whole
description on Steam and we'll be giving
some new stuff yeah stay check yeah all
right all right sounds good to me again
that's dark devotion coming out of
Hibernian Studios over in France yes yes
so you can check that out if you're
interested if you're into those souls
like games so yeah thank you for coming
back here we are going to transition to
our fifth game of this livestream so
stay tuned don't go anywhere
while we transition see you in a minute
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
and we're back with our
makes a live stream here we've gone
through four games or on to our fifth
game of this livestream showing off
project which stone Malik here thanks so
much for joining me
it's a pleasure thanks for having me of
course yeah what caught my eye about
project which zone was that this seems
like a like a very rich deep full like
RPG experience almost calling back to
divinity original sin to because that's
kind of like the the last RPG of this
style that I kind of dug deeply into so
that that's what caught my eye about
this so could you actually run me
through project which stone a little bit
yeah for sure so let's start the intro
okay so then you can play after up so
yeah there is an element of divinity in
the sense that it's in my opinion it's a
great European one that kind of brought
something new to the genre didn't go
simply let's make a classic one but
let's make something modern out of that
genre and that's kind of the same spirit
that we run with which is okay this game
start from the pen and paper RPG and
then we try to create that experience in
a you know game form and starting from
there that's where we got with project
which tone where our idea is to get that
sense of freedom that you get
independent paper RPG that sense of okay
everything is possible I can play any
character I want and it's like very
dynamic and alive so our approach with
this game is that we built the it's a
sandbox living world RPG I guess that's
how I like to call it because it's not
like we created the world that context
and all that for the game to happen in
but we didn't predefined a narrative a
story or an adventure for the player all
that is run by a I systems basically
it's like I guess I guess you could say
it's like the sandbox aspect of a game
like Red Dead Redemption but with the
RPG aspect of like Baldur's Gate or
unity okay so it's really that mix up so
what we wanted to do is like okay let's
give the player that feeling of freedom
here's a setting here's a situation it's
a world that it's a continent in this
world that just went out of her
revolution that basically it's like an
Australia of this world that kind of
kicked out the empires and said that
they were independent except they don't
really have a central government it's
basically a bunch of factions that you
know yeah and then you shop there and
everything is possible what will you do
there so it's like how you navigate
through the different factions in this
undefined world and it's exactly so you
have a huge possible impact that you can
have in this world while you try to
unify them will you try to kind of just
get rich and manipulate everyone
everything is possible basically cool
yeah I'd love to see it in action so
yeah let's take a look at that couple
things yeah so that's the main character
which doesn't have a name cuz it's so we
have classic stuff so here just to start
the demo by the way this is the first
time I'm showing this to it oh really
it's a world premiere oh okay can you
spot exclusive right here baby
so even I never demoed this to anyone
you're the first yet Wow okay we're live
streaming I'm sorry yeah no pressure at
though a man so good it goes well so
here we see an example of this is
entirely systemic in many games this
would be a scripted event something that
was predetermined but in our game
actually this town is we set it up with
a predetermined conflict like okay these
factions are trying to get a hold on a
mine that's nearby that has some
resources that both want so they're
actually in conflict in this area and
share the land you'll see that you know
there's barricades and stuff and because
it's in conflict and this guy which is
the sheriff actually decided not to
intervene he's sort of yep not my
problem so the soldiers basically start
harassing people and okay and you you
essentially have a saying how it plays
out yeah okay so you know I'll be a nice
guy could attack them
I don't know I would how does a diary
would just kill them okay
I mean well it failed so after all I can
be able to survive are you strong enough
yeah that's okay I'll make sure at all I
don't want to get you into sticky
situations so I have some all right so
there's that magic tech technology in
this game I have some real-time
reactions as well I see any of that
turn-based aspect huh okay okay so I
have a pistol - this guy - it's okay Joe
yeah so it's a very very distinctly
turn-based yeah combat is turn-based
with elements of three timer yes
so yeah yeah so yeah kind of talking
talk to me about like that that
real-time element there because I feel
like we get like this so because this
character is a fighter type of character
also a rogue anyways he's like not
success but he gets some abilities that
consume sort of resources if it was a
mage it might have been manna or
whatever different classes have
different types of disabilities and
there are trigger points for these for
example this guy when he successfully
hit someone in melee he can shine a kick
with it and knock down the enemy or if
someone misses an attack against him he
can counter-attack so he has a bunch of
tools like that because of his class
of other abilities to believe in mark
that okay so she in this case I'm trying
to kick him is there any downside to
engaging with those attack modifiers as
they show up is there it's a tryst or so
if you waste them all it's not like you
work out so cause I don't know if that's
tied to a die roll or like it is that's
Firebug from this guy okay you can
control your party each distinctly
exactly you'll have full control during
combat okay outside of combat it's okay
[Music]
yeah there you go no list took care of a
gun
geez yeah yeah I mean it doesn't feel
too good about that that's fine I mean I
can get behind this I mean there's a
faction messin with the people will with
messin with the normal people I'm gonna
take them out like to be honest I'm
gonna smash the state so if you give me
that opportunity man I'll run with it
there might be consequences though I
just murdered a couple guys in the
middle of I don't know they were kind of
asking for it is the only witness and
yes well what's my goal here you decide
you're all playing all right so okay
I'll play the role play it out okay
let's make some money cuz I want some
money all right
I'm broke there's opportunities so
obviously we could join one of the
factions maybe the red ones will be
ambivalent but you know Universal
unbound and Ashe cross state yeah those
are two yeah so the Unbounce are like
former political prisoner that became a
sort of mercenary group they're really
good at combat but they're not very
refined after station was former magic
mages and scientists were researching
this area and then they kind of built
their own group Science and Technology
yeah they have some magic tech stuff
they're the ones who designed the guns
in the game and a bunch of other things
oh that could be dangerous yeah so they
are here because there was a mine nearby
with some cool resources and they also
found artifacts mysterious artifacts and
they really loved it
except the other guys were here before
select day that's kind of flowers so
okay so they're like stealing other
people's work yeah yeah so currently
they're in that cold war they don't
really go you know we can force that to
happen if you want if that's how you
wanna play it we can murder someone to
debit sense
oh is it only if they have it coming
like if there's like people going rogue
if they're messing with the town's folk
if they're trying to seize power
like I'll take them down but you know
unless if you're if you're - yeah these
guys the unbound we're messing with the
people so okay
and it's actually pretty bad for the
population here
they're kind of held hostage okay well
can can you leave us in peace all right
then uh I'm not joining them okay so
maybe the other guys that's so the
unbound doesn't sound like a like a
faction I would line up with not about
I'm not about that life so okay I'm a
man of the people that's what I want to
be I want to be a man of the people
all right so we'll help out the people
okay so you I imagine let's take it back
a step
Quest's that you're given will and on
who you what you say to other people
oh you can tell them that like I don't
want like I don't want to mess with a
faction so it'll lead to a different
type of quest yeah a lot of RPG things
you would expect from a style of RPG
some a lot of the quests are actually
not pre-generated they really depend on
the AI of the characters okay so for
example the the factions have their own
agendas these guys just want you know to
keep the land the others kind of want
the resources so eventually they might
end up fighting and the course they give
you is based on their agenda so if I go
talk to them okay let's talk to the
other guys let's I got the quest from
the sheriff to go grab some tech from
them because he's not really curious
about their new technology all right
which is fair enough well let's go see
them it's the other end of the village
but cool yeah in terms of like your
character in role-playing is there like
speech checks there's charisma checks is
there like meters that measure like your
alignment with certain factions oh yeah
as a points the correct track almost
everything you do as much as possible
ideally that's our goal so every
character has an appreciation of you for
example they track what you do right now
it just the only thing I did so far was
murder a bunch of soldiers from the
other faction which no one noticed there
was no witness except for the sheriff
yeah but either he will not get involved
in that stuff
and damn it stuck sounds like a corrupt
cop to me well he he has a good sense of
preservation let's just say that's what
yeah yeah yeah but he is quite corrupt
he you can bribe Hannity and he'll turn
the other right if you want to mess
things up and you know right yeah some
people just judging from that it sounds
like there's a lot of variation oh yeah
a lot of branching it's more than
branching it's free yeah it's a reactive
service exactly so it builds the story
based on what you do not what we decide
that should happen okay as much as
possible so there's a lot of things
possible so okay let's take a job from
these guys they want something that
someone has okay so yeah that's an ash
cross lieutenant so yeah yeah we want to
be under good size they're the ones who
message Science and Technology so yeah
so we could steal their stuff but okay
the sauce pesto oh they don't like the
there they don't seem not necessarily as
you know the hostile it well they were
still messing with the peasant but I
guess you shouldn't have gone into their
base that's not a good idea man I could
spend a lot of time instilling justice
across land I suppose I don't know all
right let me do something kind of people
who are weird just I want to show you a
system sure yeah I'm all about that yeah
I don't feel like taking the door to the
blacksmith yeah you know you can sneak
around and stuff like I'll show you know
this is sneak mode so yeah I want they
could assassinate the blacksmith oh
that's me just talk to him it sounds
like this is like a lot it's a lot of
it's very dynamic oh yeah so is idiot
son is locked in a mind we could go
there if you want to explore the mind
and the underground that the ash cross
wants and spoiler does a really powerful
artifact down there okay that can allow
you to explore the town like obliviated
that's if you want if you want that's
what we can do we can just obliviate
everything we got about like 10 minutes
oh I don't know if you can do that
within the ten minutes times I can try
all right all right like it's not what I
would do
yeah but well let's see how far we can
take this game all right all right yeah
hold on I just messed with this guy so
like I said it's very free so we can
even have like custom dialog with NPCs
there's these things that are like the
standard but now let's say I want to
persuade him to attack Wow that's you
have this shirt have a lot of influence
yeah all right let's do that let's see
if it's a tight suit I know that's a
fail oh yeah you liked you because three
yeah I'm okay hint my character is
pretty happy for this demo role three I
got nothing
yeah I guess you'll go eventually but
let's let's not waste time and go to the
darn sure sure
anyway he asked me to save his son that
decided to go on his own to explore the
dungeon it's a wannabe adventurer so
yeah we'll save him if we can right try
to do good along the way sure it's not
gonna it's not gonna counterbalance the
the terrible deeds that you were about
to do but ya knows about to use that as
sinister it yeah and then so whenever it
comes to these kinds of games like I
play a lot of these single-player RPGs I
absolutely love like Knights of the Old
Republic is one of my favorite games oh
yeah awesome gave me - yes magic from
the yeah yeah it's from the different of
Jedi it's like oh yeah yeah
and yeah one of my favorite things just
feeling like I am having influence over
that world but to create a game in which
the player feels like they do have
influence like how hard it like that
must be really difficult to build out a
world that makes sense in that regard
it's exam really difficult fortunately
it's not we didn't get in there out of
nowhere we did two games previously
stories the path of Destiny is a normal
site where we research that and did the
form of that used time loops and our two
alternate timelines to create games
where you really had an impact with your
decisions and then this one we said okay
let's really push that to the next level
we feel already we messed around with
that and it's tricky because it's a
bunch of iicense
stem that we need to make reactive and
not break each other because everything
talked to each other so it's a lot of
fine-tuning like this guy needs to react
that way but he shouldn't go that far
because then it will break the world or
you know it's really delicate to balance
but once everything works well it's like
this you know this living thing that
lives on its own basically there is an
event where I guess what's going on
they're being attacked do we help them
or we rush because like what is random
it's this is well that's a traveling
yeah good try to intimidate the bandits
last time it fail but let's see I don't
see this pretty good work so yeah okay
no bandits in here get them out here
alright look at that [ __ ] them well we
could have attacked the merchants and
steal the merchandise for ourselves you
know I'm not about that life
yeah alright let's see so yeah we're
about to go I guess into a dungeon yeah
yeah the first part is on mine so it's a
restricted area they don't want us here
so let's try to sneak around okay good I
know there I know I know the layout for
some reason I hope you do it's weird
that I know the layout
I never equip myself with the great
sword listen the environmental art I
think is really striking to me right now
it's it's very lush it's almost like
thanks yeah it's like oh well you see I
was looking at the art yeah these
obviously they might be it's got a very
I would say cartoony but it's like it's
a yeah it's a describe it it's detailed
painting yeah okay there yeah yeah does
this Tyler our director goes for his ax
he has a bad no no he saw me oh no no no
by piece
alright oh oh no I mean is clipped
it's all good no no there yeah okay
all right I guess they won't chase us
down here so now we're in the mine
section huh and they put traps there's a
reason why because there's monsters
downstairs so that's why the mine has
been abandoned at this point but I know
I need a key because I know the game so
I'll go straight out obviously now I'm
going a bit hostile against the ash
cross which we said previously with me
but you know probably what I should have
done is steal some stuff from the other
faction and as I killed em plenty V
dance oh yeah oh yeah so then we could
have read that the entire area make sure
there's no witness and blame the other
guys and steal the bomb and whatever
that is all right so hold on Allah says
Nate this guy with the great sword
nothing no hey yeah you just
assassinated my homie yeah I guess they
didn't appreciate that the right thing I
wouldn't but damn you're doing a lot of
yeah yeah great so is lay waste to these
fools
yeah you stop your party members or oh
yeah I kind of flipped him I don't know
all right no oh yeah I actually there
was the narrator that just informed me
that I there's the key
some nice wet bells here okay Oh
tempered grates for the better grades or
is it now see that stolen it belongs to
someone and that's how I can I'll tell
you yeah plant evidence yeah exactly so
I I don't know whose oh it's dirty there
okay so technically now I could attack
the other faction and start dropping
their belongings and that is mischievous
I had that's evil another thing I could
have done which obviously we didn't
totally go that route is try to go to a
diplomatic way with them and set up a
meeting with both or do it red wedding
style set up the meeting that murdered
them all when there is a yeah my
favorite option hey what's up I'm doing
oh yeah they're not attacking you no
just the regular ol mind guard yeah he
kind of doesn't what he's gonna tell me
is they locked this area cuz it's
dangerous and I said hey I got the key
and I said you're crazy
she's and he just ran away and now is it
this way no I could loot obviously
there's plenty of years all over the
place but yeah just let you know we do
have about like four minutes
alright left so I don't know if we'll
try to make it okay alright I'll ignore
this guy he's the
the son of the
blacksmith so should go down here okay
there you go I really not sure we're
gonna make it cuz this is like another
level - yeah okay it's uh in terms like
dungeon design it's uh like the caves
and the caverns it's kind of like is it
pursue procedurally generated or these
Oh hand design yeah it's helped design
we don't really need procedural
generation that's what it's a debate we
had like should we go with procedural
generation and ultimately we figured you
know it's better to have these more
handcrafted experiences that are
narratively meaningful it's preferable
to us that's how we we felt about this
because you know we can generate a lot
of environments without needing to go
procedural and the systems that make
this world alive will anyway create sort
of variations because that for example
at the top of the mind there were as
cross members like blocking this area
but they didn't have to be there it's
because they're attacking this region
and took over but it could have been
something else happening so in itself
that's already creates a lot of
differences in the full game this is
just a demo by the way that's a
super-early actually it's only a couple
of months old that's why we like to
write here people yeah this is the first
time you're finally in audience and
finger crossed nothing has bugged yet
how does it seem like it yeah that's
always so it's yeah alright I'm almost
there man
hopefully where's the exit there is
no it's on me that this murdering
everyone with my great story I mean
these are like what like nasty spiders
yeah
who cares yeah I don't want to know no
one cares today live or die that's fine
I'm sure it matters to the ecosystem but
it ya know
alright now we're in a hurry to blow up
an entire town so jeez so savage man was
it uh it was me I had I didn't was my
idea so yeah it was your idea
alright it's a very simple puzzle just
to show that puzzle signalize yeah all
right let's go I was gonna ask
multiplayer co-op is there any that of
that in the plans yeah it's in the plans
we'd love to have that because it's a
game that would really lend itself to
exactly a cause you know it's like the
social aspect of role-playing games
would be awesome and especially with
this game where it's freedom no I'll try
to outrun him limit read and follow me
I'll try to run away oh oh damn I think
I can kill him alright but if I try to
kill him oh man yeah we're out of time
ya ever run on the last minute here yeah
man
no that's all good you're gonna have the
battle play out a little bit yeah but
yeah is there anything else you wanted
to point out from our small demo here or
from our conversation that folks out
there should probably know about what
song no well we're be at the PAX East I
guess in two weeks right yeah so people
be able to play it and try different
things that we didn't have time to try
here like get all the way and blow up
the town actually or try to negotiate
there's so many possibilities so we
barely set the surface here so yeah I
mean I can imagine from all but all the
dynamic systems that you showed it's
hard to because I would I went to go
play the demo for Pathfinder kingmaker
when he came out last year yeah and
again it's so one of those it's an art
of like well those tables are deanzie
RPGs yeah so many systems that you want
to engage with
it's hard to show at all it's hard to
try and understand and engage with all
that stuff so I understand how those
things can go well yeah I really
appreciate you taking the time to
actually show this game in action so
yeah no that's uh Malik your way of
making project which stone again yeah so
if you like what you saw be on the
lookout for that I I mean you said this
is the first bill that you've shown
publicly yeah so I imagine it's a bit of
a ways off yeah
so I'm not gonna ask you about a release
date for that you know yes done when
it's done but yeah if you like what you
see definitely check out project which
is sewn again thank you so much all
right thank you all right
that is the fifth game we showed off in
our entire live show we have one more
for you so stick around for that and
we'll be back in a couple minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
and we're back with our final game of
our indie mix livestream here on
GameSpot I'm joined by Mike hi Michael
hi so man you're broke you're bringing
uh you're bringing dead static drive
here yeah okay tell me a little bit
about dead static Drive okay so my pitch
for dead static drive is it's Grand
Theft Cthulhu okay yes let's get spooky
bit spooky it's good it's it's a road
trip through wasteland Americana okay
yeah so you jacking cars
yep Jack and cos fighting with mythical
beasts mythical beasts yeah I'm trying
to survive there's a lot of there's a
lot of spooky stuff some supernatural
stuff some terrors from outside of space
and time
oh and and you're just trying to get by
all right you're gonna you're getting
wild with this game over here yeah so I
was telling my girl here that this game
really caught my eye because of the art
style and well I want to see it in
action though so if you want to get
started we'll get on in jump into it and
yeah just you can kind of like walk me
through everything that's going on oh
snap controller ain't even on hold a
little bit oh yeah yeah we're and we're
good we good
Barry yes all right cool so yeah yes
this is how starts out you're it's like
a top-down isometric in a way almost
reminds me of like old-school Grand
Theft Auto but yeah mechanically what am
i working with here right so this is
tank controls kind of it's top-down view
and you can drive your vehicle by
steering the stick you pull a trigger to
drive so I love this kind of Micro
Machines old-school isometric racing
games okay being a huge fan of them for
years and so soon as unreal fool came
out I was like man I'm gonna make a game
where you can just drive a car top down
I love them yeah and so I spent a lot of
time trying to make a good feeling
driving game and then I just thought you
know what I'm gonna make this bigger
than that I've always wanted to make a
horror game Oh doing some sick oh yeah
doing some sick tricks getting eaten by
some giant worms here yeah so what I
focused on trying to make a game that
they just had everything that I've
always dreamt of like a horror adventure
game that was also like a little bit
Moody
a little bit artistic and yeah that's
what I've always wanted
so so yeah it's turned into a survival
game oh okay yeah yeah so like from it's
very foundation like what how's this
game built and what is the player trying
to accomplish right right so it's it's
it's kind of like an anti roguelike I've
been making roguelikes for years okay
and I used to make them back when I
would like mostly text-based and I love
them to death I love a game that I can
just play that has a lot of deep
mechanics that I can just kind of I'm
just gonna sneak away from this thing I
love a game with like deep mechanics
like a great a middle gear solid right
where it's a playground
first and foremost and you can just
really explore and see the interactions
of different different systems so I've
been trying to make this game as deep as
I can and let as many layers as I can
that interact with each other so you can
you can sneak you can use your
flashlight your flashlight attracts
monsters but it also hurts monsters and
and the humans in the game there's
survivors and you can take them with you
but they also are not always trustworthy
and so determining if you could trust
them or not is not just are they a bad
person but also are they infected by
something
okay yeah I'm just trying to layer as
many systems that I can to make it yeah
does it really exciting does it ever get
like too overwhelming though cuz do you
ever feel like you get carried away yeah
because for so much of the development
I've been a one-man team okay it really
seems like I need to keep that limited
but thankfully it's not a one-man job
anymore and I have a great team behind I
can support me some artists and
animators game designers and now
hopefully it will be as good a game as
as I've ever wanted to be cool yeah so I
imagine there's also a lot of
environmental interaction oh yes yeah
stuff using it to effectively way you
can think possible yep yep so there's an
inventory you can collect items to help
your survival and it's also because it's
a roadtrip game it's a lot of the
survival items are themed around for
trips nothing to stuff another diners wo
yep get a milkshake I got a cherry pie
over here sitting I'll eat some pie
cheesy thing ate the whole thing
Sam and and it's also like I've spent a
lot of time on the road trying to make
this game and so for me stopping in a
motel say taking your luggage around
constant inspiration yeah yeah yeah it's
constant I'm constantly thinking about
that so it's I've actually got support
for carrying multiple bags you can
actually carry luggage around with you
so here I'll grab a grab a suitcase and
so you can you can make a huge inventory
for your character you can carry like a
suitcase in each hand or backpacks and
one on your back but each time you take
one it takes up one of your yeah it's
like when you're limiting yourself so
there's easy research a management
element that you have to constantly
think about exactly yeah and if you want
to if you want to have a rifle then you
can't have items in both hands and so
it's all balancing it's all a balance
again okay yes I was gonna asked like
what kind of what kind of systems
already managing though like like is
there like hunger thirst yes
stuff like that oh there is this hunger
this this there's your bladder so you
can pay the more coffee you drink okay
the more you need to pee and on that and
and there's a stamina system as well you
can see in the top left we've got
healthy with what stamina how better the
stamina actually recharges when you when
you rest so you can drive only for a
limited amount of time okay and time
progresses naturally just as you play so
every two minutes an hour goes by
how can it goes further through the game
eventually once you've driven a lot or
once you've played and in combat a lot
you'll get tired and you'll um you'll
have to slap our yeah because your
stamina will go all the way down you
won't be able to attack monsters you
won't really be able to take care of
yourself and so managing your your your
bladder your your hunger your not not
sanity I don't want to put Saturday in
the game but like you're you can't
general well be general well Billy okay
yeah and and I
we need to manage your fuel okay yeah I
was noticing that yeah castas the car
you got the fuel gauge there so exactly
yes so we can refuel if you find a fuel
pump you also should just steal a car
jeez yeah so each car has a different
amount of fuel at different health bars
as well but they also have different
performance characteristics yeah so how
quickly they accelerate that's a pretty
sweet man man your will do that thing
around like it's nothing yeah I don't
how to drive yeah and this police cause
as well oh oh oh okay damn Oh Oh Reese
dot here man
yeah that's that's crazy man I had a
friend who ran over his Tony was out for
about three months
oh yeah you do not want that yeah we
were real code we were in ROTC and we're
we're gonna have a competition next
month so we were ghost riding the whip
and we had and then the car just like
ran over his foot
thankfully that was the extent of the
damage but yes it can kill you in this
game but again yeah I don't like
consequences too like stealing cars
stealing resources yes it factors into
like social standing with other ABCs
yeah well actually every vehicle that
gets spawned belongs to a single NPC
okay and there are some NPCs that gets
boned randomly but every time they get
spawned they gets born with a car and
they have the keys to the car in their
pocket so is if you want you can
actually all come and sneak in here into
the diner and I'll show you what I'm
talking about
I don't think these NPCs have them for
the demo but you can pickpocket pocket
right in front of the space right you're
right in front of them I know exactly
you can't see it's like Oblivion rules
that's it good exactly exactly as long
as you get the little I closer yeah yeah
you can pickpocket any NPC you want you
can steal their hats right off their
head or you can give them items as well
you can no put a hand grenade in their
pocket if he is that Savage yeah but
it's like let's steal the keys for the
car yeah and to say yeah get out of here
now
but if you get caught being violent with
NPCs then they will become angry and
each major NPC we have like hero NPCs
they have their own story lines and
Oh shot really progressed their
storylines if you if you are stealing
their [ __ ] if you steal this yeah
exactly
oh yeah as I was gonna ask about like
reputation so like because automatically
and of course in horror games like you
have to think about like social standing
and you know yes
do I want to survive do I want to help
people you know I imagine that's also
gonna factor into some of the things
here in dead static drunk yeah yep and
so we we have um we have an arc a game
arc and so it begins
the game you're actually on the run from
the law and and as the game progresses
it becomes increasingly the the police
become less of a threat and monsters
become much much ok the threat as the
game progresses let me just grab yes so
I was gonna ask about like enemy types
and the kinds of combat encounters that
you will see I know we've seen a lot of
these worms that kind of spring off the
ground oh yes right so I have a number
of different types of enemies let's see
I think there's a giant spider over here
these are demo enemies just so that I
can sure as many of it in a small space
as possible but the way the game the
full game works is there's a an ecology
to every single creature in the game and
I've been inspired by zombies not by
actually I don't want to put any zombies
in the game at all but what I love about
horror the the zombie design is that
they have this fantastic set of rules
for how zombies actually behave and if
you get bitten by a zombie then after 24
hours maybe you turn oh so you don't
want to get bitten so just a single
scrape by a zombie is really threatening
I love that and it makes them far more
threatening than they would be if that
was right there much more so like that a
wolf for example yeah they're like not
just like dealing with them in
particular but the lasting impacts of
the
you have exactly yeah yeah now if you
meet if you meet a random character in a
zombie movie for example they may have
been bitten by a zombie some may need to
check to see if they're infected okay so
I think that finding ways to make oh I'm
gonna try to see oh now I didn't know
you can scale yep geometry and stuff yep
yes it's hidden stuff parents game
there's caches where survivors have
placed items and there's also multi
level buildings throughout the game and
basements and and caves courser yeah but
I I want I want every monster type to
have its own ecology that takes time to
learn and that actually can really mess
you up so enemies who can poison you
who can poison your any hitchhikers or
any companions you've taken with you so
you can't necessarily trust everyone
everyone yeah you can trust all the
people who you're playing with
yeah I think it makes the experience
just so much more fulfilling right let
me see if I can go over here and get
some gas for this so to take a step back
in this in this game there's surveilence
there's a lot of interaction with other
people
NPCs that is but what is that what is
the end goal yes now the end Co I'm
working with a really fantastic
narrative designer right now and we
retooling the end goal oh I got I can't
disclose that right now but it's um it's
far more interesting than it previously
was okay yeah but the overall premises
your whole premise is we're going on a
road trip we're going on a road trip
somewhere yeah things change
yeah your goals change pretty quickly on
oh really yeah absolutely yeah so it
becomes the the basic thing that's
remaining is that you've got a limited
amount of time before everything's going
to hell okay
it's what do you want to do with your
last limited amount of time Lea exactly
okay so from the start that is yeah yeah
yeah so this the game has so I said it
was an anti roguelike the game doesn't
it's not focused on procedural world
it does have procedural
well you know - as well but it's
focusing more on procedural stories so
the the narrative changes as you play if
you're in a town when an NPC is there
then you can interact with them but if
you're not there then their story will
progress and neither have their
experience they'll move forwards no
brunch and they'll have different
stories so if you choose not to save
someone or if you're not in the right
location you know around they have their
own lives yeah yeah okay so it's it's
it's intended to be replayed and
intended to be really and get different
results
definitely consequences to different
actions of course you do I guess yeah
yeah absolutely yeah how hard is it to I
know you said you're working with us
like a distinct narrative designer but
in terms of like I asked us earlier with
the project which zone is like we have
all these variables how do you contain
it how do you contain yourself and like
I asked you about not getting carried
away by like throwing a bunch of stuff
in there but yeah I imagine it's a
different beast to handle it's it's
really tricky to make sure that you I
want to make sure there's lots of
interest in the stories and there's a
lot of variety in them but um no I I
want to put in as much content as I can
and and come back and make sure I polish
dontation no I don't I'll tell you when
the game comes out all right so we're
gonna be my first alone man yeah well
I'll see is there more combat encounters
we can get into you wanna see let's have
a look that's possible all right let's
get in here okay okay why that escalated
quickly all right let's get away I'll
see I can try running this guy down oh
oh yeah yeah there you go take his legs
out yep yeah so there's a definite focus
on logic creatures as well because I
find it far more exciting to to have
combat encounters with large creatures
but these these creatures he have their
own ecology these start offers as NPC's
in the game and they kind of become
corrupted oh my god it's like a bee
spider with an electric stinger yeah you
let me see can I kick him okay okay that
didn't work
all right all right all right let's get
some still and the monsters themselves
they each have their is their own kind
of allegiance to their friends and
family but they they can all get over -
yeah I was gonna ask about that yeah
then or you know part of the same team
oh shut down Oh rip okay Knights on
let's get yeah like I won't ask also
about difficulty and how progress
carries over from maybe one one death to
another like what what do you lose when
you when you die like is there it's all
one continuous thing right sighs yes
yeah it's not like I'm gonna start over
after we do my old room no no it's not
what you like yeah what happens is the
game progresses when you die so when you
die you have to recover it's a fixed
amount of time oh here's our takes time
what yeah it takes time so if the game
takes a month at the moment the plan is
for a month and it's working quite well
a month of being game damn then you lose
eight hours when you die and so you want
to minimize the number of times you die
though the faster you get to the end
faster you can start again and hopefully
have a better play through okay
yeah cool that's that's how is presently
working I I don't know if that's too
hardcore for some people because I like
I want this to be a game that all of my
friends who aren't really
two games can also enjoy so I don't want
to make like a game that is impenetrable
impenetrable yeah exactly that excludes
people I want it to be inclusive and I
want it to be something that people can
play without really necessarily loving
playing combat games right so finding
that balance is actually really tricky
I'm trying to make a game that someone
who loves narrative games I want to play
because many of the people who come past
me at pax for example they'll be like
look it looks gorgeous but yeah we did
intimidated to play it yeah it's it's a
thing to of like survival games by
nature are somewhat impenetrable like if
like for example something like I almost
think of like stated decay in a way what
I'm seeing this because of like
interactions with NPCs how you manage
them and also just like the survival
elements of course yes so but something
like that is very hard to like hand over
the controller and say all right your
turn or you give this a shot it's a yeah
that's that's kind of hard to ask so I
guess like how do you overcome that by
like because you like you said you want
to throw in as many systems as possible
but you also don't want to make them
like absolutely necessary so it's like
no I don't understand this like how this
is gonna work then yeah [ __ ] I can't I
know I agree like if I was playing Metal
Gear Solid 2 for example which is the
one I love the most
okay and you've got you know you can
shoot watermelons off a table yeah but
that that's you never have to master
that to finish the game okay right and
you could also hold up guards and you
can take their the dog tags yeah so you
don't have to do that tomorrow to finish
the game I actually completed the game
too afraid of holding anyone up so I
just killed them Oh zero savage yeah
yeah and then everyone was saying how
cool it would be to finish the game as a
stealth run haha and I was like oh you
know what I don't think that I happened
in me to do that I always do not lethal
anyways yeah any time I play a style
that game like mgs well I mean depends
cuz they they force you into combat
encounters and at some points but like
right my tranq gun is what's my trusty
tranq gun director as you can see is
where it's at
we're actually been playing the Metal
Gear series in our like with Spacey
we're waiting at Oh like afterward we
sometimes we just get together and we
play through Twin Snakes we're currently
on MGS 2 but when we transition to snake
eater and taking the reins on that one
cuz I love you oh my good yeah
you didn't mean to turn this into a yep
yeah alright let's go yes so I I want to
make it so there's a lot of depth right
but if you want to play this game as
just someone who's scared as a real
horror experience and you can not pick
up a weapon and just sneak through the
hole yeah just like and other people
take cars and if you see enemies like
drive drive yeah it's a viable ballad
that's a viable way to finish the game I
don't want it to be a combat game but I
love like I'm a massive Souls fan and
I've no geez yeah nearly platinum Dark
Souls 3 which is the most painful
experience in my life more than what
most of us could say a shout out to Eric
Tay once again the man who loves those
style games he's a low-key just loves
games that just beat him to death so oh
man oh that well then I guess a natural
question out of that is how do you make
combat like a necessary thing or how do
you how do you pull someone into combat
scenarios is like will there be
situations in which the only way to get
out of this is to fight Nora okay I
don't want to have situations where the
only way to get out is to assign certain
but I want it to always be there's a
trade-off so that's like what is your
trade so the trade-off will be if you
know I pull up to a bowling alley I go
inside it's dark I see some eyes appear
in the darkness and I'm like I'm out of
here
that's fine you can get out but what's
behind those eyes right and if you want
to I guess neat pass score risk it risk
the possibility of being killed of
having to drag yourself into an early
interest I want that to be a real like
am I willing to do that and if people
don't want to do that I don't have to be
okay yeah and they can just play but
that'll be more of a surface level of
the game they'll be able to enjoy the
experience the driving the aesthetic
and then people who want to finish the
game in a combat focused way they can
play it that way as well and imagine the
story will play out differently the very
naughty Varga differently depending oh
yeah absolutely all right yeah
sweet man well I think that's all right
I actually have no idea how long we've
been going if you could tell me for
running out of time here but I think
that you know unless there's is there
anything else you want to know dead
static try thank you I've had a great
chance yeah it's uh yeah there's like so
many different independent games that I
absolutely want to see I want to show
off because I know how much love and
care a lot of these developers put into
this so for them to roll by and kind of
play it and talk us through what's going
on is a real pleasure of mine so it's
been great all right I think that'll
that'll do it for our quick little
playthrough of the dead static drive
demo Mike thank you so much for joining
me doing absolutely I appreciate that
and also I said this was our last game
for the live stream but we do have one
more thing that we want to do so we're
gonna cut to a break but I want all of
you watching to stick around because we
have a special message from the folks
who get the any exchange up and running
each GDC so see you in a minute
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
oh snap damn sorry about that but we're
back because we have one more guest here
we're not playing a game we are gonna
give a shout-out to the people who run
to any mix the mix the media in the
exchange for GDC I'm joined by Justin
here so you run you've been running the
any mix for quite some time yeah yeah
it's been a minute yeah yeah thanks for
having us oh of course yeah so it's a
lot of fun because like I said earlier
is that there's a lot of developers who
put a lot of time a lot of effort a lot
of love into games and we kind of want
to show that off because we have an
opportunity to do that because they
always come out with like really dope
games so yeah you've been doing this for
a long time so just kind of like for the
folks who may not know how much love and
care goes into any mix gives you like
just tell us about the process of what
it is to run the indie mix yes so I mean
the mix is pretty interesting it started
organically I'm also I'm a game
developer myself okay so the whole thing
was like I came up here from San Diego
oh that really yeah okay part zombies
apiece okay okay yeah so I went to uh I
went to school in Paradise Hills dude oh
this is not planned
okay I'm from Paradise Hills a little
more high school I went to SCPA okay
okay yeah while I went to pen for
elementary so is like really you like
down the street oh man like we have a
like Filipino American festival down my
street about the any mix like what does
it mean to like have this this one
congregation for all these developers at
GDC I mean it means a ton like I was
saying like my team drove up to from San
Diego to San Francisco we were in an
incubator we didn't have anything like
we were just in like a two-bedroom
apartment all of us and then we were in
this incubator and we were working
12-hour days crazy for like three months
and we had an opportunity to show our
games at at at GDC on the show for we
had like a sponsor do that for us and
what we found was
was really difficult for us to get you
know notoriety get visibility and like
just get the press to see our games and
what what happened was there was other
developers that were in this incubator
and we were like look we're working so
many hours it's hard for us to like hit
the ground running we don't have any
marketing team you know exactly because
we're coding we're doing all the hard
you know weird enough stuff to work we
have so much stuff and it was like
really before like the indie publishing
kind of blew up and so what we did was
like let's just get a bunch of our
friends and it's like really amazing so
this is 2012 so this is right like we're
indie games are starting to peak so we
were you know we were really close kind
of community and culture so we kind of
knew like all like the awesome
you know developers out there so we just
we just gathered in you know in a
kitchen area and we invited all the
press and so like everyone came and and
it was really a really great like kind
of celebration of you know the culture
but it wasn't like something that was
just me you know this huge thing it was
more like let's get all the media and
let's get all our industry friends and
then like just like let's have everybody
drink beer and play game yes and that's
that's what it started out as and then
after that we made it bigger yes time
and so like now it's kind of jumped to
this this place where we have really
amazing sponsors we're able to work with
you guys and we're able to work with
twitch and and it's we're trying to
figure out just different ways to help
developers either you know gain the
visibility they need or or create the
context they need possibly sponsors
publishers that kind of thing
connect with first-party connect with
Nintendo connect with you know
PlayStation Microsoft to do those deals
that they they may not have had that
otherwise yeah yeah so it means a real
you know like to me this is a culture
you know like we have this kind of bond
that we share because we're great so
hard yeah there's like so many
developers it's like well I'm still
working on my game and it's like how do
we band together to kind of like support
each other and that's kind of like what
I was talking about earlier I think
talking with developers of noida and
then like black future 88 is that like
you know the mix itself is in a way or
representation of how these independent
developers just like support each other
or it's like it's very positive because
everyone knows the struggle that they go
through to make something that they love
so to have a central location where like
folks like us can stop by and see
everything in one location it's like I
don't know it's just it's a really cool
thing it's real powerful for us who love
games to actually like interact with the
people and I play their games talk to
them stuff like that so like I really
appreciate what y'all do for independent
game developers yeah yeah is there
anything else that you want to lay on
the table for all the folks out there um
I'm just I would just like to say just
like I mean support your local game
development but I mean like if you just
support the culture of game development
in general and we do have multiple mixes
during the year we have some they're
open to the public only open to industry
but yeah feel free to check us out at
any exchange com on Twitter and
Instagram and Facebook and if you are
like a budding developer interested in
this like just reach out because these
developers are always willing to help
some up-and-coming who are you know like
their dream is this thing and I think
that that's like that's one of the main
points that we want to drive across is
that like you know sometimes you're
stuck in like a culture or like a
company culture that you don't like or
you're stuck in like an industry you
don't like and you have this dream to
make a game or something like that it's
like who do you look to though like
where do you go exactly happen and and
it's definitely possible so don't
pigeonhole yourself and and just feel
free to reach out to us or anyway I mean
even if you see some cool game that's
like an independent game studio they
would definitely like to hear you know
your voice yeah sure all right yeah I
can get behind that
so like support independent developers I
know that uh a lot of games that have
affected my life so you know I want to
shell out the dough to support them and
all that stuff so yeah
who knows you might be able to see the
next game that you absolutely love on
any mix so you can go to the website and
there's a whole list of the games that
are being shown off this year at the mix
so you if you don't if you're not able
to go get at least check out the games
that are on display and maybe you'll
find something that you like so yeah I
think that's all that's all I got
if you have any other words that's
opposed no thanks yeah so and I want to
give a shout out to all of you who
watched because thank you so much
it keeps me employed but also I love
showing off games all you find people
out there so yeah if there's anything
that you liked that you saw today during
the livestream definitely check that out
support these folks who are making games
and yeah thank you for tuning in to
GameSpot because we love doing we do and
yeah we'll see you next time
[Music]